hallo meine lieben freunde heute ist
black friday das amnog amino shock um
die ägyptischen mega viele rabatte mega
viele prozesse wie beispielsweise auch
dieses mal die folter oder auf dieses
top sei allerdings bereits den titel
eingeblendet bei der lieben freund zwar
face time ich heute wahrscheinlich fest
heimlich luca ok gewissen form ist es
wie facetime allerdings darf ich euch
heute herzlich willkommen heißen zu
einer neuen episode die challenge für
die heutige folge oracle mit luca kommt
von dem lieben robin bindestrich 16 und
zwar schreibt er tue so als wäre der
zuschauer von oracle ein promi
das heißt wenn ich da ich eine person
treffe muss ich so tun als ob ich diese
person von irgendwoher kenne losgeht was
ich kenne dich eben vorher ohne gott
wartet woher kenne ich dich hast du
kommst aus dem fernsehen oder hast du
hast und radioshow eine radioshow hast
du doch natürlich willst du berühmt ich
kenne ich doch von irgendwo das ist die
charity für das heutige video ich soll
so tun als ob ich die andere person
kenne also als ob die andere person
irgendein promi sein was hat wieder
nicht so gut hingekriegt leider wie
geht's dir ja danke wir jetzt auch gut
schöne grüße an beeke lisa und laura und
auch an laser luca gerne auf instagram
folgen
oh mein gott oh mein gott nicht
begreifen bist du nicht dieser bekannte
professor nein
doch klar im hintergrund hängt doch
sogar eine biologie dings ich kann's
nicht kapieren dass du da bist alter das
ist so eine ehre dich gerade zu treffen
oh mein gott ich habe alle bücher
gelesen damals kein scheiß ich bin zwar
krass gerade die ehre ist voll auf
meiner seite kann ich ein foto mit dir
machen gerne perfekt
alter hut ist
schade finde ich dich zu treffen dies
öfter hier unterwegs auf regel was ich
habe mit anderen daten gesehen
ich habe nur gerade der story gesehen
habe du fehlst mir auf instagram so
wollten die autogramm alter da waren
leute das ist ja mein gott nein ich kann
euch ich kenne euch zwei irgendwo her
ich kenne euch irgendwo her wie heißt
hier werden darf
ich bin ohne kohle und du heißt eric
eric ohne und eric ich kenne euch
irgendwo her
die challenge wird das heutige video war
dass ich so tun soll als auf die andere
person mit nico welche treffe das team
profis also dachte ich mich und dachte
schon ich wusste du du bist schlauer
professor auf jeden fall
schöne grüße an johann
oh mein gott ich kenne ich ihn vorher
mein gott doch doch gott du bist gewiss
dieses schwarze loch ist bei der gad
nacht und sonst so alles klar
ja und trotz geburt und immer schön mit
laser luca folgen heute perfekt super
danke mein gott ich kenn dich kenne ich
woher kenne ich sage mir ich habe
ehrlich ist doch ich wusste doch wer
hatte wir haben schon auf oracle geredet
ja ja ja und sonst so tillich
das ist ja guck mal hier jetzt eine
flasche also der jetzt zwei flaschen
oh mein gott oh mein gott bist du nicht
dieser dieser bekannte die die bekannte
baseball spielerin
nee du dich nicht spiel zu bild ja oder
nein
dann kenne ich dich irgendwo anders hey
mein gott ich kenne ich kenne ein
gesicht geben woher oder bist du bist du
ich spiele tennis zu machen
ich wusste dass du bist bekannte
fotografen ich hab's mal schießen gehe
ich mal setzten sich abschluss gemacht
hat extra posen hier und so ich war
letztens in köln und ich hab's
folgerichtig treffen denn was sein
stunde später genau da wo ich sein wo
war ich denn ihr habt beim bahnhof die
an sehe ich gerade erst nach regensburg
wo ist denn regensburg das ist in
süddeutschland
ja ich weiß dass köln mal gegen
regensburg gespielt hat und ich war
malen dann live stream das dann
irgendwann mal was gesagt in regensburg
richtig ausgerastet
allgemein auf instagram oder so ja ich
sage also wenn ich jetzt sage regensburg
dann hast du aus also crazy punkt locker
ja ok hab ich ja eingeblendet leute
können sie gern mal vorbeischauen ich
würde sagen die facetime jetzt noch
beziehungsweise die regeln noch nichts
mit einer letzten personen da versuche
ich die ganze zeit durchzuziehen
dass sich damit ein promi rede also
görlitz co
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da ja aber mein gott jetzt kennt nicht
irgendwoher ich kenne dich irgendwo her
doch hundertprozentig machen auf youtube
oder so ehrlich du bist du mich bekannt
oder machen
ich will auch nicht hast du schon 17
millionen weniger 13 millionen weniger
also 100 900 millionen oder 1100 da
kenne ich aus dem fernsehen
hast du eine fernsehshow hast du eine
radioshow bist du astronaut
im weltall war
du warst der erste typ auf dem mond ach
du kaka jetzt scheck ich das auch um
mein gott ich wusste dass ein problem
muss heute am start sein safe und du
trinkst gerade mondwasser von dem
mcdonalds vom mond das werk ist es weiß
weil der mond ja auch abstimmt stimmt
der und hinten ist auch weiß weil du ja
auch gerade auf dem mond bis das ist
eigentlich ja und du bist gerade
festgekettet am stuhl wegen schwerkraft
ja geil und wie ist es so da oben aber
du hast macdonald also eigentlich
eigentlich ganz gern genauer du wie du
wahrscheinlich schon merkt ich hatte
heute als channel dass ich so tun soll
dass die person die ich treffe eine
übelster problem sei aber dass sehr gut
mitgespielt was ich dir lassen kraft
alltag mein erstes foto mit astronauten
warte ich muss auch ehemals machen
geil alter jetzt war ich ja quasi auch
auf dem mond
an der stelle ich das heute wieder ist
allerdings ob hätten weiter lieben
freude mir hat mal wieder mega mega viel
spaß gemacht mit euch auf oracle hier
unterwegs zu sein ist doch geil ist ein
typ gerade einfach kopiert gespielt hat
zu beginn dachte der will doch so hack
ist dukat besteuert aber dann musste der
ok der will mich doch nicht verarschen
dann spiele ich mit welchen astronaut
also ich fand es zum mega lustig auf
jeden fall schauen
ich werde euch der heutige teile mit
luca gefallen hat das unbedingt einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier das
schaffen gibt 40.000 likes dass wir auf
jeden fall mega krass und wird zeigen
hey ya weiterhin bock auf diese serie
der letzte teil ist ja schon ein
bisschen her leider schreibt mir zudem
gerne in die kommentare wenn ihr ins
nächste video kommen wollt was ich in
meinem nächsten teil mitmachen soll also
irgendeine challenge die ich beim
nächsten mal umsetzen soll abonniert
gern meinen kanal notfalls noch einen
teil der lubu seit ich sehe halt immer
das voll viele leute sich meine videos
anschauen noch nicht voll viele meine
ich halt wirklich über 50 prozent und
diese einfach keinen teil der doku sind
einfach noch kein abonnent deswegen
abonniert doch gerne einen kanal und
ansonsten wie gerade schon gesagt gerade
des black friday im luca shop unter
anderem dieser popsong getier ist
runtergesetzt dieses wetter hier ist
unter gesetzt mit dem bunten smiley
steckte noch ein paar andere dinge
runtergesetzt also schaut dort gern mal
vorbei nur noch das heute nacht 0 uhr
aber ich lasse euch jetzt auch in ruhe
[Musik]